what makes someone pick a low tier
fang is a gimmick
what makes them struggle against every
conceivable odd to win with a character
who just isn't that good
just what
were they thinking with this guy
there's a simple answer it's because
when everyone says your character sucks
when everyone says you shouldn't win
when almost no one believes in you
that's when a win becomes a true
victory
it's going to be so close
with the poison plus the greyhound to
the pop-ups mono is going to top eight
looking forward is he gonna finish
[Applause]
have existed since basically day one of
competitive gaming which means that for
the better part of three decades people
have been warning new players to avoid
shitty characters
you want to win you yeah
i don't even like brock like that no
more man
no matter what game you play you're
guaranteed to eventually run into
someone trying and probably failing to
make a low tier work
see there's a certain honor to picking
low tiers think about it winning with a
character who just shouldn't win can be
proof that you're a more skilled player
than your opponent but low tier
victories don't happen very often
mortal coming in
smelling some blood
anti-air is good with the air to air
whatever it is he's bleeding right now
oh he is definitely bleeding he's
bleeding purple oh the exchanges oh
they're [ __ ] oh my gosh [ __ ]
menordi
wins
by a pixel that extra health coming in
handy the low tier main in that
heartbreaking loss is monopr street
fighter 5's most dedicated fung main
fung has been one of street fighter 5's
worst characters since day one depending
on who you ask he's still the worst and
i i don't know if anyone is gonna
disagree with me here
just what
were they thinking with this guy just
what i i frequently forget this
character is in this game now let's be
real here in most people's eyes fung is
absolute trash
he's slow his damage is low his frame
data is garbage he basically has no
defensive abilities his combos are
overly complicated for basically no
reward both his v skills are mostly
useless and his whole gimmick his
ability to slowly damage enemies over
time with poison can't actually kill
anyone on top of all of that he looks
ridiculous he's a seven foot tall stick
man who flaps his arms around like a
bird makes little poison clouds that do
almost nothing and then does a little
shimmy if he somehow manages to win
so it shouldn't be surprising that fung
is literally the least played character
in the game
and yet mono has dedicated the last few
years of his life to fong out of all the
characters i was just checking who has
consistent and tired normals and good
mobility and to me it was fun even
though he got
little damage
mono isn't some new up-and-coming young
player he's been a pillar of the puerto
rican fgc for years and he actually runs
the scene's biggest tournament so i run
first attack in puerto rico which is
like the big the biggest event here in
the caribbean first attack used to be
only fighting games but now first attack
has been ever since it started growing
a lot of people in puerto rico see it as
the esports event of puerto rico not no
longer like the fighting game event but
puerto rico isn't exactly known for
their fighting game prowess their top
players don't get to travel as often as
players from japan and north america so
many wouldn't consider it a top tier
region and mono isn't some chronic low
tier main he actually started off street
fighter 5 with a much higher tier pick
and in sf5 he actually played dictator
and then dropped him when dictator got
buffed what are you doing but once mono
made the switch to fung he had his work
cut out for him
remember no one plays fung there's not a
lot of tech out there to study and in
fact most of the top players who used to
play fong switched off the character a
long time ago so mono was one of the few
players creating all of the fangtech and
he had to get a little creative to
optimize the character i see like a
super huge punish
with akira on rose and then i'm like hey
i think i think wong can actually
recreate something like that or that
situation i think fong could do
something that and i just theorize it i
just test it out and i find stuff like
that because it's that's because i told
people that playful i'm like it's really
hard to just find
all the match-ups with fong
in youtube like it's because he's an
uncommon character
but mono couldn't devote all his time to
mastering a weak character
i don't have the same time available as
many of the professional players to just
dedicate only to playing like i play but
i also produce
mono did his best to go to as many
tournaments as possible and became the
face of fung mains everywhere but he
quickly became known as one of the best
fung mains in the world
and then the pandemic hit throwing the
entire fgc into chaos
tournaments went on a line introducing
lag to matches which made tricky
characters like fung even more difficult
to play and yet mono started popping off
poison could be added up as well yeah
just stained power crouching and then
dodges it to the sky as well
i can't believe we made it through that
that was so slick my man's kept it
composed this is actually dangerous for
right now oh
okay it could have been even worse uses
one ex still gets hit and mono brings it
all the way back to take a 2-0 victory
over dra and puts himself in top a
winner's bracket continuing that
momentum indeed unfortunately those
incredible wins were quickly followed by
close crushing losses
okay stealing a bit of a turn was mono
there rather than just the medium he
usually does oh this is a punish this is
mana medicine now that's all he needed
was one opportunity here trades on the
wake up tries to meet with the air
doesn't get it but he doesn't get a
grounded hit either so scrambles on
scrambles
but no charge my goodness it's so
unfortunate they have the charge right
because the cross-up blows that up and
resets with the throws he's able to take
a live lead from it
he's going in thrown out of the
roundhouse i can't believe it he's in
big trouble there's a mena sealing the
deal three games to one mono's solid
online placements earned him a spot at
red bull kumite las vegas one of the
first major offline tournaments after
years of online play even offline though
mono just couldn't crack the top players
no neutral november
i'm gonna start celebrating now why are
you trying to [ __ ] him capcom please
oh geez
oh geez
oh man oh geez
oh man oh jesus what is this what's
gonna happen oh my god oh my god oh my
god
you did that brian right now did you
just do that you are a bad man despite
mono's incredible skill it seemed like
fung couldn't take him to the top
but then
something crazy happened
red bull kumite was a big deal but it
was a closed invitational something that
many in the fgc might not consider a
real tournament no to them a real
tournament is a grueling double
elimination bracket where hundreds of
players vie for dominance
and ceo 2021 was going to be the first
one of those big offline brackets in
years with 453 players in attendance
mono showed up ready to play alongside
dozens of his countrymen but that meant
the pressure was on obviously i wanted
to do good because of the fact that i
mean i'm with the team i don't want to
be like going with the team and i'm
their number one street fighter
representative and i don't make it out
of pools so i was like a little worried
because i'm like i really want to make
it out of pools
mono didn't have too much to worry about
he had a clean run through pools two
owing every opponent he faced to make it
to top 24 on day two of the tournament
but now he had to start facing down some
serious competition from top players
playing top characters
but mono didn't care
got away from one throw landed one of
his own now mono has to likely and an
antier two bars to kill with he can set
up a trap here he did but the jump out
was so huge yes that's amazing
back dashing of fierce
activation here there it is
be shifting out nephew now completely
resourceless oh he can't drag the crush
there's still no meter
over the anterior it's going to be so
close
with the poison plus the gray after the
bump up mono is going to top eight
because i have never been able to get to
crack in to that ceo entrance i've
always loved the concept i've never been
able to get it and i've always would be
like a top 16 almost close to top 16
almost close to top eight almost close
to top 32 but never top eight making top
eight was beyond anything anyone could
have predicted for mono and he made his
entrance in style repping his
underappreciated local scene i host most
of the tournaments in puerto rico but
like you know using venues and stuff so
i would at uh weeklies i would do in my
apartment and i was like well i can fit
up to maybe 12 maybe 16 people so i was
doing like 16 man brackets on the
weekdays i did the first one
and it was
more than 16 people came because others
just wanted to see it and i had water
people be like oh can i get a water yeah
sure no and they would go to the fridge
and go get a bottle of water because i
buy cases right but i lived with
roommates so
the next day when i wake up the
roommates are like yo
where are all the water bottles that we
bought and i'm like
you're kidding me because some people
actually went to the fridge and they
didn't let me know that they were gonna
get a water so the next event i'm like
okay so i'm just gonna charge at least
one dollar for the bottle of water so i
can replenish and buy cases obviously
because they're consuming and they're
not bringing them on water so but then
it just became a joke because people are
all like oh you go to mona's house and
he charges you the water in the summer i
was doing puerto rico's first like
esports league with street fighter and
the last day
we actually had a bottle of waters and
they had like my face in it then one of
the puerto ricans that was with me that
knows about the story is like we should
do this too because they're all gonna
know why we did it but mono had some
tough matches ahead of him
first came joe umarogan an up-and-coming
akuma maine hasn't shown time and time
again you can't do
that you can't walk back
over the other dark board
stealing it
after barely making it into winners
finals mono had to face off against his
biggest challenge yet
punk
punk is without a doubt one of the best
street fighter 5 players in the world so
there's no denying that punk is like of
all time street fighter 5 the greatest
in my opinion rivaled by tokido as me
that's the one guy
the stats peg him as the third best
street fighter 5 player of all time he's
got countless tournament wins and grand
finals appearances in both capcom cup
and evo he's an absolute monster that no
one wants to face in bracket
in fact he's so good that up until
winter's finals punk was casually
dumpstering his opponents no names and
top players by beating them with vega
another low tier pick hold on now
there's the activation that's what park
has been suffering is against this
feature attack
he's out of there to jump
takes it over christine
going into that winners finals match
with mono on one side and punk on the
other it seemed pretty clear who was
gonna win mono was using one of the
worst characters in the game to go up
against one of the best players in the
world
but there's a reason low tier mains
stick to their guns there's a reason we
keep playing our bad characters even
though everyone tells us not to
because we believe
and mono believed that fung could take
whatever punk threw at him he has a
really good vega he has really strong
vega but how much does he know vega fong
is a very is a very big thing if he
knows the intricacies of what he can
punish what i can punish that he hasn't
seen because
maybe he's played with other thongs but
not maybe to the level that i play it
you cannot activate here if your motto
jumped away from the ex mono needs this
as he takes
[Applause]
sending nephew to losers and top 16 he's
not done with panda
he's not done not done with him
grand finals
mono did it he was locked into grand
finals guaranteed at least a second
place finish
but second place was a place mono knew
all too well fung might love the number
two but a true competitor wants more
mono wanted to win it all and he'd have
to face his demons again to pull it off
after his upset loss to mono punk
switched off the vega he was using to
troll the tournament and went back to
the top tier character that made him
famous
karin
neptune has him in the corner activation
but punk has super right and this could
we see the patented oh man not better
than you y'all saying and i better hear
y'all say it because that's gonna be a
stupid situation parked with the victory
over nephew three one to get it done and
put himself in grand finals
to fight model once again with a run
back
karen has long been considered one of
the best characters in the game and she
fits punk's playstyle perfectly i just
punk on karen man that pun that's that's
built different that is the loadout of
player and character that fundamentally
changed the way this game is played
she's fast with long buttons that help
her whiff punish things like fong's long
slow limbs her damage is extremely high
helping her kill off of errant hits and
even when a character like fun corners
her she has spectacular defensive tools
basically karen is one of fung's worst
matchups and punk is easily the best
current player in the world on top of
that punk was angry since like any great
player he hates losing so this wasn't
just a rematch it was personal the grand
finals meant a lot to mono this was his
chance to break his second place curse
his chance to prove to the world that in
the right hands fung could do anything i
know i can beat this character i wasn't
sure if i could beat punk but i would
know i could beat the character
rekka's record pressure is respected we
back dash the poison continuing to take
away here
so model games that he could take it but
it's getting harder and harder if he
feel is helping out though don't work
with damn buddy
and with all that grey light we're gonna
die for the just the two bars we don't
even need to cash out with the super
second game on the board for punk
building a little bit of extra variables
that should close out this round i think
but he finds the fierce anyway to face
[ __ ] with the recess
punk demolished mono it wasn't even
close punk reset the bracket with a
vicious 3-0 and everyone thought the
tournament was basically over sure mono
had another set to work with but after a
loss that decisive it didn't seem like
there was anything he could do to run it
back
and yet mano's belief in fung was
infectious everyone wanted him to win
are people booing right now they're
booing him they is that one when he's a
villain
the villain because it's mono's story
it's mono store he's a protagonist bro
like i had the headset on but i could
hear the chance with mono and it was no
longer that small crowd of puerto ricans
on the side it was literally
a lot of people in the venue and i was
like
this is surreal what the crowd didn't
realize though is that mono wasn't just
losing he was getting the download on
punk
so i i'm confident that fong can beat
karen i just i felt that when i lost the
set i'm like you don't have to change
you just have to adjust mono didn't
switch characters he didn't make massive
changes in his play style he just went
into the second set ready to play
win or lose he was fighting for low tier
mains everywhere
and he didn't miss
him off the feet with the sweep
try to open him up
that door looking easy to bust open
though the medium just commit just yeah
he's gonna be able to close it for the
game yes he is a game on the board for
mono we're at a point where this is one
touch for either player
with the ex dash any poke will do it
it's the same thing from the winner's
side
two games post bracket reset in part to
get the poison stacks away which means
that we're not getting actually
he gets banned
you drop the combo though
champion street fighter 5 20 21 gets it
done mono is the hero of the game mano's
win was more than a crowning achievement
for him as a player he helped legitimize
the puerto rican scene proving that it's
a region to be feared and respected but
more importantly he reminded everyone
that tier lists are just about which
character has the easiest time winning i
feel that in street fighter 5 especially
right now where it is
i feel like
you can technically play any character
it's just
it's a matter of
how you approach the matchups because
sometimes there are things with players
like the most important thing in in
every fighting game
is not necessarily how you play the
characters or what the characters offer
but it's more
so
how fast you can adapt
mono's run stands as undeniable proof
that low tier mains can win that even
when everyone tells you your character
sucks even when everyone tells you you
made the wrong choice hard work and true
skill can always triumph
like they said that i was like an
example of the fact that that it can be
done that you can have other stuff going
on but you can if you
dedicate the time or
it's not out how much time but the
quality of the time that you dedicate to
the game then you're able to pull
something like this off and so i think
both david and i would like to have a
formal apology
to mono
about telling him to switch away from
fong otherwise he'll never win a major
tournament
and uh
shout outs to mono dude
it is i mean like japanese wise it's
it's cutting but like you just say karen
it's fine
she's not a real person she's not going
to get upset you know
she's not going to she's like
yeah she's not going to come out of your
screen and tanko you
i know how much you want to be stepped
on by cara and andrew that's clearly the
vibe i got there but